vous savez pourquoi vous êtes invités
non parce que marion maréchal-le pen a
refusé mon invitation elle était invitée
vendredi
ces salles on fait la vue aux produits
de remplacement j'ai parlé dans une
interview accordée au quotidien
catholique d'extrême droite présents
marion maréchal-le pen revient sur le
remboursement de l'avortement
il faudra revenir sur le remboursement
intégral est illimité de l'avortement
car les femmes sont des êtres
responsables qui doivent être traités
comme tels c'est pourquoi ne vient pas
non pour ne pas parler de l'avortement
mais les divergences qu'il a quelques
compromis
son émission a avorté je ne remettrait
pas en cause l'accès à l'ivg et j'ai de
quelque manière que ce soit donc
j'espère que les choses ont été entendus
les français savent que vous ne ferez
rien ou presque dans les quelques
semaines qui nous séparent de l'élection
présidentielle ils savent bien c'est que
le dernier gouvernement de françois
hollande ne fera pas en quatre mois ce
qu'il a été incapable de faire en quatre
ans
je voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
pour la manière très bienveillante
absolument aimable avec laquelle vous
avez eu la gentillesse de me souhaiter
la bienvenue
les ministres ont néanmoins le droit de
soutenir tel ou tel j'imagine que c'est
quand même je sens du message du
ministre de l'intérieur d'accord
l'intérieur de l'intérieur je voyais
j'ai du premier ministre paris - le
permettez vous êtes 3 je suis seul
laissez moi une 44 cas le cas pardon
puisque madame oui c'est un jeu pour
quoi seriez vous seriez vous d'ailleurs
excepté mais pourquoi pas du tout
j'espère qu'il va se faire engueuler la
maison qu'on peut pas se présenter comme
ça du jour au lendemain à la présence de
la république
donc ça chaque chose en son temps on
n'avait jamais eu l'ambition non pas
pour pas pour cette fois en tout cas je
ne sais pas après on peut jamais dire
jamais un de plus à son tour vincent
peillon ancien ministre de l'éducation
devra annoncer sa candidature à la
primaire de la gauche
l'opération vincent peillon
j'ai du respect est une opération
pathétique pathétique parce que il
s'agit uniquement de dézinguer un autre
candidat marc avait beaucoup de
candidats
ça change pas grand chose non je pense
que ça ça pas de répercussions
importantes en visite cet après midi
dans le doubs l'intéressé réagi mais à
l'écart des caméras on ne peut pas être
candidat pour affaiblir
c'est ma conception on ne peut pas être
candidat contre moi vous ne souhaitez
pas vous présenter aux primaires de vous
jeter par la fenêtre et je m'en charger
personnellement
[Musique]